previously on raft by putting these here
we will have eggs soon freaking cooking
table going up here who would be me
don't look at Bruno Let It Go
these [ __ ] are not giving any eggs I
don't think that's how you get eggs
I think you get eggs by having a chicken
pen because I remember there being a lot
of eggs in our pen of chickens that we
had at one point Marcus getting too into
the cooking his his veggies are all done
growing and he's nowhere oh they just
they must have just
sitting there withering on the very fine
no no
so I know you got really into the
kitchen Thing Mark did we ever set up a
computer
right they don't have eggs yet where's
your eggs
I got it we got a signal boys we got a
signal
[Music]
turn left
this is gonna be way more annoying to
get to without it without engines and
stuff it's okay how's that heading keep
lifting I mean I turned the sail in that
direction but yeah go the hell exactly
that way good good we're closing in on
it we'll be there in 10 000 years
we're gonna be there literally forever
forgotten why we're going this direction
by the time we arrive yes it will be
sudden and jarring and then uh very
strange like my first time we can't turn
the boat can we there's no way it
doesn't rotate until we get the rudder
oh Rudder because we don't have engines
now we can't
um
wait haven't we gotten so much more
stuff have we researched any of it uh uh
oh
no I looked at the research and there
wasn't anything that we like didn't have
hmm that's a very likely story you said
you want Vine goo more Vine goo
if you got it I don't need it as much
anymore I made do but we could always
use more Vine goo yeah I can't find
anything that we have in our boxes that
we ain't researched yet damn son where'd
you find that
all right well it's going to be an
arduous Journey but we can get through
quill you said there was none what you
just quilled do we have a feather we
haven't done feather or dirt I just I
just opened a box feather here here
feather feather and dirt feather dirt
where's dirt dirt was in here yeah we
have dirt go get dirt did you put Vine
goo in there did you research the goo
yeah I checked that we've researched
Vine goo and we researched leather and
mushrooms did you I don't think so it
would be 15 feathers I just needed
because there's how many I had they're
not they're not egging up there they're
just Feathering so give me the feather
research did you do it yeah the mushroom
does not have a researchable thing but I
didn't leather leather leather yeah
bananas metal Arrow oh
that's a nice thing uh explosive powder
I need to research I need to craft it
and research it okay what else water
bottles we need to make and research
water bottle dirt still needs to be
researched for the dirt I thought
someone got that where is the dirt yeah
I got it
we've been sitting on whoa what I I had
to cough it came out okay cool good
we've been sitting on so much stuff
I was so full you know what it worked
because it still ended up on the ship
but I was so full those birds will never
lay eggs and I hate them for that I
don't want to say that I told you so so
I won't all right I think I need to cook
up some of this explosives how's our
heading uh navigation good heading we
have made it about 1 8 of The Journey
excellent
can you turn the boat with your panel I
don't think so it doesn't really rotate
it just pulls wait why are cave
mushrooms in this box aren't those a
food thing did you research mushrooms
they're fine almost so we have here let
me look at this thing uh
[Music]
how do you make titanium
Titanium Ore which you get explosive
powder
I'm researching I'm cooking up explosive
powder right now everything if only I
had an egg dude
I don't know they're not egging I wish I
hadn't thrown that one at the chicken
yeah I was like wouldn't this be ironic
if I egg the chicken did you did you
actually I don't know is that a thing I
would do yes you tell me man hey we're
going over jellyfishes whoa they're so
beautiful
they'll be their friend yeah wait wasn't
it a thing where they added like
creatures in there is there like whales
there's no sea creature well so you can
see sea turtles you can see a whale I
think you can't do anything yeah but I
don't want to see you creatures they're
not they're not do creatures they're
seeing no I don't go to the aquarium to
do The Creatures there uh you don't no I
don't do you loser what
what what
they're sorry what are we talking about
what oh
my mistake
I'm sorry we need to find bees we need
to make water bottles that's what yeah
we're going to the first island we
should have been doing this a while ago
I apologize but uh
it didn't happen it didn't happen
I I I'll I'll take that with me to my
grave water bottle is four Goose six
Plastics how many dudes we got we got
Goose
don't we have seaweed that's just like
not cooked I just put some in yeah some
guy I won't name who but just doesn't
want to make goo
some guy as the raft keeper I want to
say that that's some specific
individual's priority but
um
I'm really
really monitor in this societal
structure and I feel like whoever is my
gatherer is really letting me down
wait those are the same thing whoever's
neither a hunter nor gatherers really
let me down
whoever runs in between hunting and
Gathering whatever intermediate steps
there may be whatever third role there
is you know ancient humans Hunters
gatherers Mark
I've always I've always wondered why
those surveys for old people who are
dead uh from the wow words keep going I
always wondered why it was Hunter's
gatherer or other now I know what the
other is for yeah I'm researching this
water bottle and then we can make our
own water bottles
wait but we you made a watermelon it
unlocks more
binoculars we need those oh oxygen
bottles actually sounds pretty good yeah
that's pretty dope okay so now we need
honey wool titanium wow when they make
shears and get wool from a sheep or a
llama or whatever the hell on an island
probably yeah this next island has got
to have some goodies on it we have got
to find we in all honestly we need a lot
of those puffer fish you keep going on
you're gonna throw that far oh can I for
mine oh double barrel
oh that's really embarrassing it's so
beautiful my confidence is shattered
it's all right man and your life is over
dude you can't be a sigma whatever the
third role in human society is that I am
male oh called this one did you see this
predicted it's Hunters gatherers and
sigma males
that's what the roles are yes we all
know we all know right Sigma higher or
lower than Alpha higher
what beta Behavior where's Giga chat at
on this list oh that's a different
classification anyone can be a giga Chad
yeah
[Music]
did you research the explosive powder I
guess that's what I was thinking yeah
what did that I was cooking up um more
Goose that you guys can make water
bottle what did what did we get the
explosive from the explosive powder as
far as the net canisters
um
all right we're halfway there boys holy
[ __ ] I'll start battling yeah that's a
decent idea I'll make one of them
I'm not sure maybe all three of us
paddling would go super fast I don't
know hey Mark have you learned that you
can paddle from anywhere on the boat
including inside of it really
oh
I think you can even possibly paddle
from the Second Story I'm gonna try it
uh
I don't have one
we're paddling up a storm boys all three
of us together we're blazing
we're blazing we're zooming lads
we're Zoomers
why is that you're just standing still
paddling what did you do look I was
trying to move I don't know
plane I couldn't if I wanted to are
those things created eggs yet I'm so egg
needing I bet they don't they did not
just more feathers they should they must
egg maybe you need to set the mood Mark
maybe you're sure we don't need a
chicken for eggs right you're sure we
get seagull eggs I don't I'm pretty sure
he is
I'm just I may have said that a long
time ago and we waited a long time
pretty sure that's becoming increasingly
likely to be the right answer but
I just I don't want to rub it in
anyone's face but I'm just saying nice
to have faith my bro okay I bet the
moment we get a chicken captured and put
it in a pen a seagull will lay one egg
for you Mark I bet I bet it'll happen
who wants to be net launcher guy this
time because I was net launcher guy last
time
um I can try it we have the stuff to
make I'm gonna need like two Nets I
think we're gonna need like 50 rounds
though because I'm pretty trigger happy
well then we're gonna need a lot more
puffer fish than what we've got cat
Navigator man how much progress have we
made now towards our goals a sea
together
we are 550 meters away we need to go a
little more due south west is that left
or right from our current heading it's a
little left from the current heading so
we're headed west ah toward the port
yeah basically how's that heading uh uh
probably good yeah yeah basically uh how
it works is the Nets are facing north so
that's how it is period okay did you
hear a water bottle Bob yeah I'm good
you guys good enough do you have a water
bottle yeah you guys got water bottles
I'll take a water bottle I look out you
said that wait like one of us already
had one but you you started the water
bottle thing I just been like hey
anybody need one of these you guys buy
bottles I didn't know if you guys had
one or not I'll take I'll take one these
are one for me come on bottle daddy
working on it working on it you need
more goo I got Goo uh oh no all right I
don't need one I determined it
sounds like someone else's problem
hey I'm rowing the whole raft over here
all right it's a lot of responsibility
you're right
these days
you know what I think I was just holding
my paddle in the air rowing nothing
because I was looking slightly up
well win some solution you know
for like the last couple of minutes I
was doing the same thing and my brain
was just like this is supposed to Splash
when you paddle
[Laughter]
same thing uh
God you know what that sounds like my
problem I gotta be real honest it sure
does God damn it okay Mark there's two
Goos in here and there's two cooking so
once those are done all four of those
are yours for your bottle uh you want
two Goose I told you I had Goose you
want Goose you can make it now just grab
six Plastics I'm real busy that day
foreign
that's not my problem they were so close
guys
I bet yes did you start paddling I'm
making another paddle
we're getting there much bigger than I
thought they would be yo okay you're
good these are magical big why is it
like that they're so big okay
[Music]
no I'm just marveling in what nothing's
up here he's just looking at himself in
the mirror like oh it's so much bigger
than I remember it dude that I thought
it would be oh just take a second to
yourself and go oh my God so big wow I'm
strong
no just me just me maybe it becomes
bursting in behind you Mark I told you
stop doing that while you're recording
every look at this time
all right guys that's an old reference
stop roasting me alive here hey hey
I mean where's my wallet
okay so this is getting a little
ridiculous you know because you forget
your wallet a lot I do I do lost it in
the Korea oh [ __ ] but you found it or
before you found it I have it great I'm
really unclear what's going on with
Mark's wallet but that's fine same
sounds like somebody else or does not
have it at this time at this time in
point no at this point in time that's
how words work this time point this time
and point this time points to yes
yes
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hey what's happening Dad
don't look what happened oh look hey
wait guys is there an enormous raft off
to our left am I losing my mind
is that where we're supposed to be going
that that sure looks important that
place that we just didn't go to what
what happened a navigator is the place
to actually sound like yes yes
very near
I happen to look at that direction for
half a second oh I can feel it in my
bones my knees excellent excellent oh
Jenny's nearly over
I'm almost out of paddle anyone else got
any more paddle you won't need to where
we're going
indeed I will need to until we get there
though I think yeah no
oh okay okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're so easily swayed
uh is this an island or is this a rig
it's a it's a it's a hang on it's a it's
the radio tower that's what it's called
okay so there won't be goats good to
know no probably not the next thing we
go to I'm pretty sure is an island of
some sort with stuff crafty the lofty or
not yet you know
crafty the wafty who's crafty the wafty
uh you know crafty bear
oh I love that song keep going finish it
I don't know what that's probably finish
it
finish it
I don't know
um
wanting for a harvesting down here let
me guess they just finished yeah
they just finished you're about to just
finish oh babe sure I hope so sure sure
that's a structurally important one
that's so important
we should maybe build around that oh God
let me just how about that
I just do that for a minute
I would have destroyed all of the most
important [ __ ] that we have oh maybe
that would have been fine I was honestly
a big deal as it seemed like it was I'm
pretty sure yeah yeah
the plastic why
oh what is that sound that doesn't sound
like anyone else's problem what happened
I think we're actually getting further
away if I'm not paddling us directly
towards the objective thanks no no no no
no we're definitely saying exactly still
yes
yes and I really hope my third paddle
gets us there man I really wish I could
help my hands are tied ah if you're busy
this day I've been so busy doing
anything else really uh me also I've
I've you got I'm yeah oh wow this
sentence keeps going huh wow
it's really our
eggs
yeah you want more of this have you
heard of
hey I just realized something
what does this sound like does that
sound good although you're talking
through a toilet paper roll I have a I
have a little drink Koozie that fits
right over my mic perfectly
it actually is a it's an interesting
effect I I gotta admit that is like an
echoey walkie-talkie effect yeah it
sounds like I'm on Old Time
now we know what
it would like to be sitting in a glass
jar
and someone talking to us you want to
know what it would feel like if you were
sitting in a glass jar but you were also
miniature sized I've always wondered
just now oh it would feel like this
weird I feel that in my soul
anyway we're almost there okay my
paddle's gonna break before we get there
though again no no no you guys have
extra paddles believe
remember what I had resources instead of
broken paddles
I don't I do not remember that who was
this
stop giving me tilapia is a mackerel is
this the wrong fishing pole
this is metal what's the deal with
tilapia and mackerel yeah okay this is
where we're gonna anchor then because I
have no I'm not making another battle
for 30 feet come on Bob no that's it
we're done Mark use your paddle
down it would be away
lying that's oh this is not a good way
up is the shark alive suddenly that
matters very much for me yeah I'm
paddling closer I guess he doesn't care
are you probably closer
down I did it Bob did why would you put
the anchor down what's wrong with you
with anything I'm fishing all right let
me know what I'm about to hit I can't
see over the what December 12th we
stopped for the night no I hear it oh
okay radio still works all right should
be two weeks before we reach the moon
because the team's not responding
you might say things are a bit dense
the other facilities are underwater so
if Celine is lost
or nothing
and now Sparrow's not talking to either
of us
I really hope we're not the Last Hope
For Humanity
same are we the last helper humanity is
that what's happening now we're The Last
Hope For Humanity
we'll have to repopulate oh me first
which
part
a dick
yeah I think that's what you use for
that right I weren't ready for that one
I remember School
this January oh ooh it's been weeks oh
just me and Owl here now is stuck on
this platform
Sparrow took the boat what the heck I
can't figure out why
thing is just so secretive I mean I
don't even know their real names
you got it they needed more people we
were supposed to be those people
and together we would find a way out of
this mess
somehow
are selling up in the tower
or maybe the radio picked up something
you Sparrow
I know we've been here before and this
seems like a lot more uh story than I
remember experiencing during the beta or
whenever we played this yeah it is it's
nice it's nice nice
very nice it's nice
oh now I have hiccups great thanks game
guys you want to see something huge
what's your thing Mark man just whoa
22nd of December this dress call
received Balboa Island
9th of January how cool won't accept
facts
2nd of February gunshots in the distance
of February sparrows calm
6th of March another distress call
varuna Point amazing child
16th of April Rafters dreaming of Utopia
foolish hope
I love her optimism yeah that's I feel
good oh no guys I'm full and I found a
strawberry colada that's good thing
though right you sounded so sad I
thought he's full oh it's a recipe for a
strawberry colada oh we don't have
strawberries though it's no time
February
he picked up a lot of signals
maybe someone will come and help us
we're not starving
yet
might be the only chance we have against
this
[Music]
genuine Sparrow
owl things you betrayed us but you must
have had a good reason for leaving us
here I hope you make it to silly
I hope you finish the reactor
for all of us
you guys should come to the top of the
tower
I'm working on it I don't remember this
being a thing that was here does it not
all remember you oh hey we needed that
right
[Applause]
I don't know if you could tell by the
reaction I figured that that meant yes
what's up there do I need do you need me
to come up there too need no I just I
just don't remember this being a thing I
guess Bob could let us know if it was a
thing yeah let me know if that was a
thing I was doing some rearranging on
the old raft of ours was this a thing
that was here
what why are you talking about it like
that it's a person because I didn't
remember there'd be another people wait
there's a person up there that I don't
think there was a person wait a minute
we can talk to wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
I'm coming closer
no I'm approaching I'm approaching you
watch this that's really saving a lot of
time buddy I'm on where am I who am I
coming up Mark up which way is up
um go to the right that's right I got it
I got it yeah there you go I got it yep
yep yep yep yep yep got it in in yeah
find the staircase yep yep yep yep
uh-huh that way yeah yeah yep yep yeah
right wrong wrong no wrong wrong no no I
was wrong keep going yep vines vines
climb vines no no no no no no no no no
known parkour parkour parkour oh my God
you are good at this game yep yep yep
good calculated calculated intended not
in here not in here no no no no no no
more up yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah oh god oh you're so
good at video games
can we have your radio you bored or
something what oh holes hey a friendly
face you don't know that I wondering how
I ended up here long story
really really long story we're wearing
Boar's masks and tilapia faces
need any repairs done let me know I've
sort of ended up as a maritime expert
namely due to the world thinking
awesome let's head out are you a captain
new playable
come on get on the moon
whoa she's gone wait yeah what's this
happening it's awesome oh
God okay oh God is there fall damage oh
you could survive this oh God I survived
it yay oh
oh yeah that felt great hey the shark
hey the shark knock it off I was so far
away oh he did blueprints how do we how
do we do this learn them learn them I
don't know if you put them in the
research table or what yes oh hey
recycler learn oh hey look at that
about
guys have you seen what's upstairs no
because we were busy exploring the world
what I did a thing wait simple battery
we need to make a battery then research
the battery oh I can do that here let me
do that I have a battery ready made a
headlight too I have a battery up here
let me let me slam it in there
oh God those stupid cats are in the way
research learn done nice nice nice nice
what the frick
I said nice nice
I didn't ask you to do it again oh we
can make out more smelters nice nice
nice nice nice nice nice nice
oh I just made a lot of nails did you
guys get an oh that's fine did you guys
hey you guys need some Nails let me know
did you guys manage to get a new
coordinate set it's in the journal hit t
for sure
and then and then you could find it
right two three three oh two okay
all right we need to go oh was that not
yeah okay we're going more weast you
guys remember weast you liked weast
right did I love the way yeah we're
gonna keep going that way great anchor
up
are you asking or saying done it's done
okay sale
yeah
sorry did that not did that not hit you
the same way it hit me I feel like I
knew what he was doing I felt it I'm
with him I'm cool I'm cool
do I just throw These Blueprints out
after they've been researched I think so
uh yeah I think guys have you not seen
what's going on on the upy UPS I'm just
not even gonna come upstairs on purpose
now it was soups up here if you want
soup just trying to look at this
infinite wood I know right I found the
infinite wood hack Bob don't you want to
look no not really but you want to look
oh my God you can touch the Wood Wow
wood
come on yeah they grew really fast I
planted them right after you got on
there they're almost done cool wood it
is cool
harder and harder to get to why why is
this that's not even a food chest
anymore the food's supposed to be
upstairs
yeah downstairs is the fish foods to
cook on the grill the grill should be
upstairs I'm just gonna put that out
there I could put it move it but last
time I moved something someone was
really mad move the big grill to where
it belongs but the fishing happens down
yeah the fishing happens down so who
cares but the cooking happens up so why
does it matter where cookies right here
not if you move it but then the fishing
can't happen up can it yeah it can
actually uh yeah I can actually I
suppose it could be food production all
upstairs like we could make the
fisherman I refuse to use stairs does
anyone know the button to drop stuff
you're holding in your hands there it is
no what is it
okay goodbye item that you were holding
did you just Chuck something we have a
trash can you guys know this right I
don't do we have a recycler can I move
uh one I'm gonna move the water and the
oh I need water actually the water in
the the croplets upstairs that'll create
a path here so you guys yes excellent
yes and then all the water upstairs is
kind of unconvenient but yes you could
do that no there's two there's one down
here I know but you can't fill it from
upstairs so it's you have to go up and
down the stairs right not optimal but
you may do that I you are the ship
master or whatever am I wow I bet you're
the ship keeper so you're the one who
has to deal with that mostly uh God
knows I don't refill the water after I
drink that's wow I do
[Laughter]
I like this way of getting people well
that's the one I was gonna move I
appreciate you refilling it weight but I
gotta move it oh I just was waiting for
the Harvest to happen I'm just gonna put
these out here
so the shark thinks this is an important
place to attack yes
stupid shark oh I think this is done
yeah this definitely is done
oh that's that's a whole that's a full
one that's a fuller one oh [ __ ] I'm
killing your baby Mark yeah please do I
my inventory is so full I can't even
deal with it I can't even look at it
specifically right now because all of
them are open uh I would say just like
smell whatever you can okay we have 13
goose
way more sand probably
I don't think so okay I think they
buffed how fast these trees grow because
oh yeah they used to not grow as fast
I'm pretty sure yeah well son of a [ __ ]
you okay my stupid ax broke sorry man
gonna be all right there's an island not
gonna be all right
dramatic over here golfing
in my lungs saliva is perfectly
satisfactory Mark did you get a palm
seed from the oh I see
yeah do you have any more Palm seeds to
replant these bad boys I have so many
um it's in my um uh food prep area
oh my God no we had a box with a bunch
of plastic in it I think oh we're down
to one stack of it well we should be
actively collecting it as we Cruise the
dirty dirty ocean
truly is filthy but also our salvation
Salvation comes at the cost of wisdom
[Music]
wow that's a quote from Diablo the
original I don't know where I pulled
that out of but it just came to me
I had like a [ __ ] Vision I mean hold
on to that the wisdom is uh pretty
impressive all right we're in business
boys we are going to be at our
destination in just as much time as it
originally took to get to the first one
excellent but right now why are these
grills out in the middle of [ __ ] what
I explained what I was doing those are
sharks your ideas are bad those are to
attract the thing over here oh well that
seems to be really undercutting my
original statements we have so much
metal we could outline outline our whole
I I mean we could but also we're gonna
we're probably gonna need that for stuff
or something I always put that up there
when it needs to go down
I was up when I needed down
oh me slap me what the hell is happening
I'm angry at me don't you hear me
yeah you're right I do I do I'm sorry oh
me well I'm disgusting God I'm filthy
all right uh
uh what do we uh did we get anything we
could build in the last one what was the
dealer recycler metal Lantern wow
for recycling we need plastic Metal
Ingot hinge bolt and circuit board well
the only thing we don't have of those is
circuit board I think yeah these plastic
copper and vinyl we have all right I'm
making a recycler we have all this [ __ ]
we can make circuit boards yes yes
please do that I need that first I need
that
oh yeah oh I forgot we have a recycler
guys
[Music]
that's why we keep the nest out because
it makes the birds not go for crops oh
oh you guys aren't nearly as
flabbergasted about these things
trees in the the trees and guys look how
easy to their Lorax
oh we also need a battery for that I
forgot
um
I know where the batteries are oh oh are
we out of clay you that would do today
but we learned a table we got the table
suddenly I care that we're out of
plastic okay there we go guys we have a
recycler
and it is
from
function
your confidence there it is it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine what
should we get rid of we shouldn't get
rid of this
I'm gonna get rid of all the flower
seeds guys I added something to this
[ __ ]
oh
Sparky yeah
I'm sorry Mark I'm offended for you
that was my honest to God reaction to
that what do you want from me I suppose
you know I do believe that was truly
your reaction that I don't doubt how
does this work how do we put materials
you need to put stuff into it and it'll
poop out trash Cubes but it only
recycles raw materials so like dirt uh
stuffed plastic wood all this stuff oh
dude the Palm leaves we have so many
Palm leaves oh we do have a lot of Palm
leaves
whoa that's so much warm light
foreign
[Music]
there we go Bob hang on hang on
I'm throwing away leaves hang on
well I'm right here man
I'm literally you're you're ruining my
experience all right I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
these are cool little uh Brazier yeah
it's so much brighter now I thought it
was nice nice this is nice you know what
that's nice thanks man anyone checked
other notification recently because I'm
seeing a nope that's not it we're
probably good we could check it I'm fine
probably must be a broke I can't do
anything about this situation okay okay
okay okay
I'm here to help
him he's gone thanks Bill let me check
that heading
oh
whoa guys
come here I learned a magic trick
that's not it Mark that's not that's
just smashing trash into it watch this
see how this is a regular one and this
is a nice one yeah you learned it
upgrade
wow
[ __ ] sorry I thought we were showcasing
our moderately cool experience okay
you're right you're right you're right
I'm sorry that was I've I apologize I
should have been more accommodating
although that requires stuff Foundation
armor is expensive yeah yeah it is
that's why I found dated this
for that great to be over I got it uh
what and is what is that what is
happening I saved a crate and I'm happy
about it okay dalston's great
okay okay
God I hate myself
oh my God
I can't even think that that was okay
what I said was not okay man it must
have been really bad he's never
apologized or something great the shark
no ow I save you [ __ ] it's gone oh
thanks buddy really
got my back I guess I thought I was back
in the boat no I was just eating my ass
yeah I cared a lot more than I should
have did that sounded mean too but I
didn't mean it to be
just keep going oh my neck oh oh no not
his neck oh God damn it I shook my head
I shook my head Mark are you just
standing staring at sparking I'm
building stuff
I'm I'm trying to make it so that we
have a lovely place to cherish great
thanks Mark yes yes awesome oh I forgot
about Wall Storage right oh interesting
yeah you can attach it to walls it's
awesome oh really good
yeah great thanks Mark
what do you put on a shelf I don't even
know
I think that's more of an aesthetic
thing but you put elves on them ah
[Music]
um
rocks the session's taking on a really
weird tone guys I gotta be honest
I don't know if I'm comfortable with
that yeah it's all right I'm crunching
rocks
we have two trashcups I was trying to
poach your Barrel off
how'd that shark field nerd yeah
because I'm fully fed because someone
made all this food we took all of our
copper ingots and where are they I oh I
am having them okay I will put them back
I am having
I have had them and I am having them
where do we want to store these um trash
cubes that are being made uh somewhere
valuable because they're very valuable
how many how many trash cubes per
something good we need like a bunch it's
like one trash Cube but to get like cool
stuff it's like 10 20 30.
you need a lot of trashcups man I'm
[ __ ] up this cast
oh [ __ ] me
it's like under oh well not good I
whiffed it guys I biffed it and whiffed
it
straight up biffed it even I straight up
Biff whiffed it that's just embarrassing
really I am embarrassed man Foundation
armor is expensive I heard that
somewhere these two trash cubes are
going in with the soup that only makes
sense yeah no I get that I get that uh
how much to make a trash Cube again
a lot of crap uh but how much crap
specifically does it Benefits full
Stacks like yeah we put in like a few
full stacks of leaves
uh yeah I mean I could make I'm more
croplets and just make more beats they
literally it rains beats when you just
cook or make them over and over again so
as long as you don't cook them yeah raw
beets it has to be raw material I barely
even need to cook it's only four for a
single soup like That's how little I
need it's more expensive for the clay to
make the bowl than it is for the beets
themselves they grow so much just wait
until you make shark heads too we
actually have the stuff you need to do
that recipe but I don't think we have
that recipe oh foreign
not going the right way
what are you doing looking at the
directions you looking at me maps we're
going like Northwest and we need to be
going like Southwest yeah yeah yes what
the sailman is uh I thought you said
weast
oh the sale is closed well we're just
going whichever direction then hmm good
that's Beulah
well no one's at fault here let's just
let bygones be bygones for now uh okay
makes sense and it's not at all
conspicuous I will I made it serious if
we find a sheep or goat I'm gonna get it
let's not let Wade near any goats or
sheep all agree do I disagree
aye motion I disagree
the eyes have it oh I just have it I
said hi but I disagree
um the eyes have it
let me shave a sheep is that all you
would do yes I'm not gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ]
Mark didn't you say there's some kind of
time you need to end or something oh
yeah we've been oh God oh God I forgot
life existed outside of this game we've
been recording for a long time
there's other games we were going to
play today what happened to us I guess
it's just rap today I do fun all right
they had a good time I like this game
I'm glad people like watching it if only
they would have told us man it must be
so sad when it ends and they have no
other way to listen to our beautiful
voices afterwards ah darn it if only
there was something out there that
double
came out every week I wasn't done yet
but yeah it's distractible
yeah
yeah all that coming
I don't know and we should I've not done
it a long time also we saved the game I
should sue to do that same world man
that would have sucked to lose all that
progress
I mean how much progress did we really
make today some only an incredible
amount
um only an astonishing this whole second
floor and whatnot you know ah good point
good point all right but anyway there's
links in the description also and also
in the I card do you know what the I
card is no uh should I know what that is
is it bad if I don't know what that is
it probably is given that you're a
YouTuber in a way I also don't know what
it is the information card it's right
here I'm basically cupping it with my
hand like a testicle you cut mine yeah
I'll cup yours I'm cupping it I'm
cupping it okay I don't know where it is
but I'm doing something somewhere anyway
you can find distractible it's
incredible and if you listen to it your
penis will grow or your
vagina vagina will grow
we know how to reach our target audience
yeah that's that's what everyone's
looking for it's true it's not true
oh
okay now I'm lost all right well they
won't be lost when they go fine
distractible wherever the link may be
it's a hidden it's a game it's a
scavenger hunt find the link you'll get
all the content
[Music]
thank you